am Dienstag ist völlig überraschend der
Präsident des Europäischen Parlaments da
wird sasuli im Alter von 65 Jahren
verstorben aber jetzt hast du die wurde
1956 in Florenz geboren er studierte
Politikwissenschaft arbeitete als
Journalist zunächst für eine Mailänder
Tageszeitung ab 1992 wechselte er als
Reporter zum öffentlich-rechtlichen
Fernsehen in Italien wo er lange Zeit
für verschiedene Sender unter anderem
als Moderator tätig war im Jahr 2009
wurde David sassuli Mitglied im
Europäischen Parlament und Teil der
sozialdemokratischen Fraktion unter
Martin Schulz
2014 wählte ihn das Europäische
Parlament zu einem seiner
Vizepräsidenten und im Sommer 2019 zu
Ministerpräsidenten
David sasuli verstand sich als
Brückenbauer für ihn war das Europäische
Parlament ein zentraler Ort wichtiger
politischer und gesellschaftlicher
Debatten er hat stets klar Position
bezogen und sich dafür eingesetzt die
Menschenrechte gerade auch bei
strittigen Themen wie Asyl und
Migrationspolitik unter allen Umständen
zu wahren
wir verlieren mit ihm einen Mann mit
Haltung und einen leidenschaftlichen
Europäer da wird sasuli hinterlässt eine
Frau und zwei Kinder unser tiefstes
Mitgefühl gilt seiner Familie ich bitte
Sie sich für einen Moment des Gedenkens
zu erheben
ich danke Ihnen dass Sie sich erhoben
haben wir verneigen uns vor dem
Verstorbenen
[Musik]
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren wir
sind heute zu einer Sondersitzung
zusammengekommen weil die
corona-pandemie mit der Variante
omecron leider wieder Fahrt aufgenommen
hat die gute Nachricht ist dass das
Impfen der Bevölkerung in der
Bevölkerung vorankommt mehr und mehr
Menschen nutzen auch die Möglichkeit
einer Auffrischungsimpfung das
sogenannte Boostern
ommikron ist aber nach allem was wir
bislang wissen noch anstreckender als
die bisherigen Virusvarianten und
verbreitet sich daher sehr schnell im
gesamten Bundesgebiet wir haben auf
unserer Bund auf unserem Bund
ländertreffen am vorigen Freitag darüber
beraten wie wir trotz hoher
Infektionszahlen das öffentliche Leben
aufrechterhalten können die
Bundesregierung hat jetzt um Einberufung
einer Sitzung gebeten damit die
vorliegende Verordnung möglichst schnell
auch vom Bundesrat beraten
wird und damit auch in Kraft treten kann
die Regelungen sollen die
Voraussetzungen dafür schaffen dass vor
allem die quarantänezeiten für
infizierte und Kontaktpersonen verkürzt
werden beziehungsweise ganz wegfallen
können
bevor wir in die Beratung der Vorlage
eintreten habe ich noch gemäß Paragraph
23 unserer Geschäftsordnung
Veränderungen in der Mitgliedschaft des
Bundesrates bekannt zu geben aus dem
Berliner Senat und damit aus dem
Bundesrat sind am 21 dezember 2021
ausgeschieden der Regierende
Bürgermeister Kollege Michael Müller
Frau Bürgermeisterinnen und Senatorinnen
Ramona Popp der Herr Senator Matthias
kollatz die Senatorin die alle kalacci
die Senatorin Sandra Scherers die
Senatorin Elke Breitenbach der Senator
Sebastian Scheel Senator dr Dirk
Bernhard und Senatorin Regine Günther zu
ordentlichen Mitgliedern des Bundesrates
hat der Berliner Senat am 4 Januar
bestellt Frau Regierende Bürgermeisterin
Franziska Giffey der ich an dieser
Stelle ganz herzlich gratuliere und viel
Kraft für die Arbeit Wünsche Frau
Bürgermeisterin und Frau Senatorin
Bettina jarasch und Herrn Bürgermeister
und Senator dr Klaus Lederer sowie Herrn
Senator Andreas Geisel die übrigen
Mitglieder der Landesregierung wurden am
selben Tag zu stellvertretenden
Mitgliedern des Bundesrates ernannt den
alten und neuen
bundesratsmitgliedern gratulieren wir
und wünschen ihnen für die Arbeit eine
glückliche Hand wir bedanken uns bei den
ausgeschiedenen Mitgliedern und für die
Zusammenarbeit und wünschen ihnen für
die Zukunft alles Gute
besonders danken möchte ich an dieser
Stelle unserem ehemaligen und
langjährigen Kollegen Michael Müller der
seit der neuen Legislaturperiode seine
Wirkungsstätte gewechselt hat und nun
Mitglied im Deutschen Bundestag ist
Michael Müller ist ein waschechter
Berliner geboren und aufgewachsen in
Berliner Bezirk Tempelhof arbeitete er
nach einer Ausbildung zum Bürokaufmann
zusammen mit seinem Vater in dessen
Druckerei und begann seine politische
Laufbahn als Bezirksverordneter in
Tempelhof
1996 zog er in das Abgeordnetenhaus von
Berlin ein nach der Berliner Wahl im
September 2011 war er zunächst Senator
für Stadtentwicklung und Umwelt und
wurde schließlich im Dezember 2014 zum
Regierenden Bürgermeister von Berlin
gewählt damit hat Michael Müller unserem
Haus über zehn Jahre als Mitglied
angehört und war in der Zeit von
November 2017
bis Oktober 2018 auch Präsident des
Bundesrates wir haben ihn als ruhigen
und besonnen Politiker kennengelernt dem
die Belange und vor allem die Menschen
seine Heimatstadt ganz besonders am
Herzen liegen dieses Engagement für
seine Berlinerinnen und Berliner wird er
nun zwar an anderer Stelle aber
sicherlich auch mit derselben Tatkraft
im Deutschen Bundestag fortführen für
diese neue Aufgabe wünschen wir ihm
alles erdenklich Gute bei der bisherigen
Berliner Bevollmächtigten Frau
Staatssekretärin schäbli bedanken wir
uns für die gute und vertrauensvolle
Zusammenarbeit im ständigen Beirat und
wünschen Dir ebenfalls für die Zukunft
viel Erfolg neue Bevollmächtigte des
Landes Berlin beim Bund ist damit ab 23
Dezember Frau Staatssekretärin
Anna-Maria dressner die ich sehr
herzlich im Haus begrüße
die Tagesordnung meine Damen und Herren
liegt euch liegt ihnen in der
ausgefertigten Form vor es gibt einen
einzigen Tagesordnungspunkt und
gibt es zu der Feststellung der
Tagesordnung eine Wortmeldung das kann
ich nicht erkennen dann gilt die
Tagesordnung als festgestellt und ich
rufe den Tagesordnungspunkt 1 auf kobit
19 Schutzmaßnahmen
Ausnahmeverordnung als Wortmeldung haben
liegen mir vor einmal der
Ministerpräsident dr ran Haseloff und
dann der Minister Prof dr Lauterbach
Bundesministerium für Gesundheit den ich
heute auch sehr herzlich bei uns begrüße
lieber Rainer Kollege Haseloff sie haben
das Wort
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrter Herr Bundesminister liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
zuerst wünsche ich Ihnen auch alles Gute
zum neuen Jahr möge es ein Jahr sein was
Lösungen
herbeibringen lässt die wir dringend
brauchen und die auch die Menschen
erwarten wir wollen dieses Jahr auch
gemeinsam nutzen um das was uns schon
fast zwei Jahre lang intensiv bewegt und
belastet entsprechend in eine bessere
Zeit und in einer besseren Situation zu
überführen
wir sehen tagesaktuell die Dynamik die
in unserem Land stattfindet wir sind
keine Insel wir wissen dass das ein
europäischer Prozess ist dass wir bei
offenen Grenzen und einem offenen System
tatsächlich erfahren welcher Wellen auch
bezüglich der Pandemie und der
jeweiligen Mutanten durch Europa gehen
und dass wir auch innerhalb der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland die
verschiedensten Entwicklungen sehen die
aber von einem geprägt sind die
Inzidenzen sind zu hoch die Impfquote
ist zu niedrig und wir haben hier noch
eine enorme politische Arbeit zu leisten
um das was wir uns vorgenommen haben
nämlich die Pandemie dauerhaft
zurückzudrängen auch zu erreichen wenn
trotzdem optimistisch dass wir es
schaffen politisch sind wir eng
beieinander was auch das gemeinsame
Verfahren anbelangt die Sitzung der
heutigen zweiten Kammer des Bundesrates
also zeigt auf uns der Bundesregierung
dass wir jederzeit schnell und bereit
sind gemeinsam zu handeln und das
besprochene und entsprechend auch
vorbereitete auf den Weg zu bringen und
möchtest auch über eine
Kommunikationsstrategie so an die
Menschen nachanze bringen dass sie es
verstehen und deswegen ist es gut wenn
nachher Herr Lauterbach hier ebenfalls
noch mal für die Bundesregierung einiges
auch versucht so klarzustellen dass wir
es dann wissen unsere verordnungslagen
hinein transportieren gerichtsfest
machen aber auf der anderen Seite auch
so verständlich machen und immer auf dem
aktuellen Stand lassen dass wir weiter
arbeitsfähig sind fakt ist aber eins und
das sage ich jetzt hier ohne dass ich da
große Interpretationen mit verbinde die
pandemische Lage von nationaler
Tragweite wurde beendet das ist
politisch auf der Bundesebene Geschehen
mit Bundesregierung der jetzt hier in
Mehrheit im Bundestag und das ist
erstmal Fakt daraus resultiert der klare
Auftrag an die Bundesländer mit einer
gewissen Eigenständigkeit Ihre Probleme
zu lösen wir haben aber auch über die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und die
Prozeduren der letzten zwei Jahre es
geschafft dass wir die wesentlichen
Dinge ich würde es mal mit 80 bis 90
Prozent bezeichnen gemeinsam in 16
Bundesländern organisiert haben und
gemeinsam auch getragen haben und dass
wir natürlich auch bezüglich der
Dynamiken und der unterschiedlichen
Betroffenheiten und wo es geografisch
anfängt und wie es durchläuft durch
unser Land entsprechend auch jeweilige
Differenzierungen vornehmen und das
zeigt sich ja heute auch an den
inzidenzbild ein Faktor 6 in der
Unterschiedlichkeit von Norden zu
Mitteldeutschland zum Beispiel zeigt
dass wir eben auch diese Differenzen
gemeinsam auch durchhalten müssen wohl
wissend dass die ihnen die jetzt
niedrige Inzidenzen haben auf höhere
zusteuern und das möglicherweise da wo
jetzt maximal Werte hoffentlich dann
schon erreicht sind dass diese Werte
entsprechend dann auch wieder nachlassen
und so ist das ja auch von uns in den
letzten ein dreivierteljahren immer
wieder auch beobachtbar gewesen
wichtig ist aber dass wir auch mit der
Häutchen Verordnung zeigen dass wir in
der Lage sind gut zu analysieren und
auch entsprechend die Notwendigkeiten
nachzuführen und damit also auch dem
Rechnungen tragen was ich in einem
veränderten Krankheitsbild an einem
Verlauf in den Symptomen in der
Inanspruchnahme der Krankenhäuser
generell aber auch der
intensivbettenkapazitäten für uns als
Aufgabe da ergibt nämlich dass wir uns
schauen anschauen wie lange muss eine
Quarantäne sein was ist mit den
Impfstoffen die wir einsetzen was kommen
für neue Impfstoffe was muss sozusagen
dort auch genehmigt und dann auch als
Standard für uns nicht nur zur Verfügung
stehen sondern auch den Menschen zu
erklärt werden dass wir die nächsten
Schritte auch gemeinsam gehen können
deswegen ist wie gesagt die heutige
Verordnung die wir hier verabschieden
auch ein Hoffnungszeichen dass wir
nachführen nicht nur im Sinne von
Verschärfung sondern auch im Sinne von
Absenkung bestimmter Belastung die wir
bisher zum Beispiel durch eine
Quarantänezeit von 10 bzw 14 Tagen und
so weiter und sofort je nach Lager und
je nach Festlegung auch der
Gesundheitsämter zu realisieren haben
und dass wir auch bestimmte
medizinischen Möglichkeiten eben auch
abbilden in dem was wir an
Freiheitsgraden neu zulassen das heißt
dass wir auch an bestimmten Stellen auch
öffnen und damit also auch bis hin zum
Ressourcenmanagement in der Lage sind
auch durch die neue Mutante erzeugte
ressourcenenzüge zu bewältigen so dass
das gesellschaftliche Leben nicht an die
Grenze kommt bzw wir weiterhin auch den
Staat als funktionsfähigen die
Gesellschaft als entsprechend
lebensfähig auch darstellen wichtig
Arbeitgeber Lauterbach ist aber an
dieser Stelle auch auf eins hinzuweisen
weil sie ja mehr oder weniger auch eine
Regelung
jetzt treffen lassen durch nachgeordnete
Bereiche durch das Paul-Ehrlich-Institut
und das Robert Koch-Institut dort sitzen
Wissenschaftler die mit großem renommier
verbunden das Vertrauen der Bevölkerung
haben und wichtig ist dass bei aller
abdelegation aus ihrem Ministerium und
damit aus der Bundesregierung in die
Zuständigkeit was die detailfestlegung
anbelangt dieser beiden Institute klar
ist je nach Zuständigkeit die einen für
jetzt in dem Zusammenhang Impfstoff für
die anderen für die Quarantäne
Laufzeiten dass das ganze nicht
politisch übersteuert wird wenn solche
Behörden politische Anweisungen bekommen
was opportun zu sein hat
dann verlieren wir das Vertrauen was wir
dringend brauchen dass es auch zukünftig
eine Politikberatung aus der
Wissenschaft herausgibt und wenn wir uns
darauf stützen dass man uns abnimmt was
wir für staatliche Maßnahmen auf dem
Verordnungswege zum Beispiel dann auch
damit verbinden wir brauchen Vertrauen
wir brauchen Vertrauen in die Maßnahmen
ihr Schränken schließlich Grundrechte
ein wir brauchen Vertrauen in die
Impfstoffe wir brauchen Vertrauen in die
Prozeduren in die Frequenzen wann wir
impfen wie oft für Ostern und so weiter
und so fort und das geht nur mit einer
unabhängigen Wissenschaft die auch in
den Behörden bzw in diesen Instituten
vorhanden ist und nicht politisch
optriert werden dürfen das ist meine
Bitte weil wir bei all den täglichen
Gesprächen die wir führen immer wieder
auch diese Unsicherheit verspüren was
macht ihr politisch getrieben und was es
wirklich faktenbasiert und das ist muss
unsere gemeinsame Aufgabe auch in der
nächsten Zeit sein so wie ich ab wir
müssen auch noch auf einen Fakt
hinweisen möchte weil ich Daniel letzten
Tagen unwahrscheinlich viele Gespräche
geführt habe nicht nur mit
klinik-chefskrankenhaus Verantwortlichen
sondern auch mit unmittelbar sich
betroffen sehen den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern bei der Umsetzung der
berufsbezogenen Impfpflicht ja
Berufsgruppen bezogenen Impfpflicht
müssen wir darauf schauen wie wir das
machen wie eine freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung anders als
andere Systeme mit anderen Philosophien
verbunden damit umgehen in der
exekutieren im Umgang und so weiter und
so fort es darf nicht sein dass wir
sozusagen dort Wege beschreiten die auch
zu erheblichen Ressourcen Entzügen
führen
die uns vor die
diskussionslager stellen inwieweit wir
generell mit unserem politischen
Anliegen was die Impfpflicht anbelangt
langfristig eine Mehrheiten der
Bevölkerung behalten und da ist Bewegung
drin hängt viel auch von den Märztagen
ab wie wir damit umgehen und da bitte
ich Sie ausdrücklich dass nicht nur im
Sinne des Ermessens ausübens bei den
Gesundheitsämtern zu lassen zumal die ja
dann auch in der Zwickmühle sind auf der
einen Seite die versorgungsseite zu
sehen in einem Landkreis zum Beispiel
und aber die medizinischen
Notwendigkeiten natürlich eigentlich in
den Blick nehmen müssen wann es
sozusagen das mit welcher Stringenz und
härter auch durchzusetzen das muss
gemeinsam besprochen werden und das
können wir nicht im sozusagen im letzten
exekutiven ausführungsglied der
Gesundheitsämter die eine ganz
hervorragende Arbeit in den letzten
Monaten und zwei Jahren geleistet haben
und die unter Stress und völliger
Belastung sehr sehr viel für uns auch an
politischer Arbeit gemacht haben nicht
nur fachlich auch politischer Arbeit das
darf nicht bei denen hängen bleiben das
müssen wir politisch lösen das müssen
sie auch mit einer klaren Vorgabe
entsprechend auch so versehen dass wir
hier keinen zumindest partiellen Kollaps
erleben ich glaube nicht jeder
Schlagzeile die irgendwo produziert wird
aber wenn sozusagen dort Hochrechnungen
von bis zu 25 Prozent von
praxisschließung oder Reduzierung im
Raume stehen wann verängstigt dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger schon jetzt und
dem müssen wir etwas entgegenhalten und
das ist meine Bitte auch im gemeinsamen
miteinander auch vielleicht für den 24
bei der nächsten MPK dass wir darüber
reden wie machen wir das damit wir nicht
das Kinder mit dem badeausschütten nicht
überziehen und trotzdem eine stringente
pandemisch
begründete bzw auch Pandemie einen
dämmende Strategie weiter gemeinsam
verfolgen und ich danke bisher auch für
die Zusammenarbeit und für das gute
Miteinander aber sage auch noch mal sie
haben das mag das Schloss der
Schlusssatz sein sie haben die
pandemische Lage nationaler Relevanz
sozusagen beendet und deswegen sind wir
Länder eben nur einer besonderen
Verantwortung und deswegen muss auch
eine Bundesregierung akzeptieren dass
wir dadurch aus auch unsere eigenen
akzentegebung und Akzente ersetzen und
akzentgebungen vornehmen damit wir an
dieser Stelle auch die große
Unterschiedlichkeit und die zeitlichen
unterschiedlichen Verläufe entsprechend
abbilden da bitte ich um Verständnis
aber ich glaube das bekommen wir
weiterhin gemeinsam hin wenn wir sorgsam
und behutsam miteinander umgehen
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank dr Haseloff und ich darf nun
das Wort erteilen Professor Dr
Lauterbach das unseren
Bundesgesundheitsminister
herr Präsident meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren ich darf mich zunächst
einmal ganz herzlich für diese
Gelegenheit bedanken es die erste
Gelegenheit die ich habe hier als
Bundesgesundheitsminister zu Ihnen zu
sprechen mein Dank
gebührt ihnen auch weil sie so schnell
zusammengekommen sind um diese beiden
wichtigen Verordnungen zu diskutieren
und möglicherweise zu verabschieden ich
konnte beim letzten Mal nicht persönlich
erscheinen weil an also Termin ist
unmöglich gemacht hat aber umso mehr
freue ich mich heute dabei zu sein ich
will ein paar Worte zur Zusammenarbeit
zwischen Bund und Ländern in der
pandemiebekämpfung vorweg schicken so
dass sie eine Einschätzung haben wie ich
die Dinge bewerte und also was der
Hintergrund auch unser Zusammenarbeit
sein können zunächst einmal möchte ich
mich auch noch mal ganz herzlich
bedanken dafür dass wir so schnell
miteinander zusammenarbeiten konnten ich
habe jetzt schon an drei
ministerpräsidentenkonferenzen
teilgenommen wir haben einiges auf den
Weg gebracht und sie haben mir sehr
schnell die Möglichkeit gegeben hier
also in diesem Team so ist es ja zu
verstehen mit dabei zu sein dass hat
meine Arbeit deutlich erleichtert und
das möchte ich auch in den Vordergrund
stellen ich glaube ganz allgemein was
die Zusammenarbeit zwischen Bund und
Ländern in Deutschland gut funktioniert
und sich auch in der Pandemie bewährt
hat und das auch das oft
angegriffene Instrument der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenzen sich
bewährt hat wir sind in Deutschland
besser durch die Pandemie gekommen
bisher als viele andere Länder die in
der Altersstruktur mit uns vergleichbar
sind wir haben eine geringer
Sterblichkeit ich habe früher als
Ratgeber an mpks mit also auch
teilgenommen im Hintergrund ich glaube
das ist eine Konstruktion die
funktioniert weil man sich auf
Bundesseite dann vereinbart es muss aber
ja von den Ländern umgesetzt werden und
die um Lösung hat im Großen und Ganzen
sehr schnell funktioniert und
funktioniert bis heute dass man eine
Einschätzung von daher ist das also für
mich auch ein besonderer Moment dass ich
zum ersten Mal Tal der MPK bin als
aktiver Teilnehmer und nicht nur als
Berater und auch in dieser Funktion rede
ich hier
was besprechen wir heute
die Pandemie ist an einer Schnittstelle
angekommen wir gehen jetzt in das dritte
Jahr der Pandemie und das sind ganz
besonderes Jahr weil in diesem Jahr wird
sich für uns die Frage stellen gelingt
es uns die Pandemie so zu entschärfen
dass wir in die sogenannte endemische
Lage überkommen dass nur noch
sporadisch Ausbrüche vorkommen und das
nicht mehr viele Menschen an sarskopf
zwei sterben müssen das saskow 2 nicht
mehr eine Bedrohung ist für unsere
Gesundheitssystem das sask of 2 nicht
mehr den Schrecken mit sich bringt das
möglicherweise hunderttausende
infizieren oder verlassen wir diese
Gelegenheit die sich in diesem Jahr für
uns ergibt lassen wir diese Gelegenheit
ungenutzt passieren meine Einschätzung
ist die wir müssen diese Gelegenheit
ergreifen und wir haben die Mittel dafür
wir haben den Mittel dafür die Pandemie
in Deutschland in diesem Jahr
weitestgehend zu beenden das wird nicht
ins Land gelingen wir sind privilegiert
weil wir Möglichkeiten haben die viele
Länder nicht haben aber wir müssen diese
Möglichkeiten auch nutzen und auch ich
werde hier auf einige dieser
Möglichkeiten jetzt zu sprechen kommen
wir dürfen nie vergessen es sind schon
zu viele Menschen an dieser Pandemie
auch in Deutschland gestorben und wir
können in diesem Jahr diese Welle von
Todesfällen beenden wir sind jetzt
mitten in einer Welle die durch
besonders starke Ansteckung geprägt ist
die omegonwelle und man darf nicht den
Fehler machen dass Omicron Virus zu
unterschätzen
omikon ist sehr viel ansteckender ist
mit den klassischen Methoden der
kontaktbegrenzung nur sehr schwer zu
begrenzen es wird aber oft vorgetragen
die Studien wurden ergeben
omecon ist etwas was man bekommt woran
dann aber nicht hört erst in den letzten
Tagen ist eine sehr wichtige Studie aus
Berkley oder Berkley Universität in
Kalifornien vor sagen wollen wo man
sehen kann das halbe Risiko ins
Krankenhaus zu müssen ein Viertel Risiko
dass man intensivmedizinisch versorgt
werden muss somit sollte man meinen okay
dann ist das jetzt etwas was näher an
der Grippe ist und nicht mehr so nah ist
an der corona-pandemie das ist dezidiert
nicht der Fall wenn sie sich hochrechnen
was das bedeutet ein Viertel so viele
intensivfälle bei einer
verbreitungsgeschwindigkeit wo ich eine
Verdopplung alle fünfeinhalb Tage habe
dann kann man rechnerisch sehr schnell
in eine Situation kommen wo man bei
einem Viertel der Belastung der
Intensivmedizin trotzdem sehr viel mehr
Menschen in der intensivmedizinischen
Versorgung hat als bei der Delta
Variante die uns so viele Probleme
gemacht hat auch die Sterblichkeit ist
für Deutschland noch nicht ausgemacht
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt ist es so dass in
den Studien die ausgewertet worden sind
diejenigen die infiziert waren in der
Regel der mittleren Altersgruppe nicht
den hohen Altersgruppen angehörten und
dazu kommt dass Deutschland auch eine
unglückliche Kombination hat wir haben
eine alte Bevölkerung das ist zunächst
einmal gut die Lebenserwartung ist hoch
in Deutschland aber somit haben wir
viele alte Menschen die viele
Krankheiten haben und von dieser älteren
Bevölkerung ist ein besonders hoher
Anteil im Vergleich zu den Ländern mit
denen wir uns vergleichen nicht geimpft
das ist die Sondersituation wir haben
somit sehr wohlhable Menschen die
gleichzeitig nicht geimpft sind und mit
dieser Sondersituation müssen wir in
Deutschland klarkommen daher sind auch
die Ergebnisse der Studie in Berkley
nicht eins zu eins auf uns übertragbar
und auch nicht die Studienergebnisse aus
England wir sind nach wie vor in einer
Situation wo wir auch eine hohe
Sterblichkeit durch die omegonwelle
nicht ausschließen können und müssen
daher vorbereitet sein die Beschlüsse
die wir heute fassen sind wichtige
Elemente der Vorbereitung wir haben uns
auf die 2g+ Regel haben wir uns
verständigt die wir es heute nicht
beschlossen wird ja von vielen von ihnen
bereits umgesetzt dafür danke ich Ihnen
im Namen der gesamten Bundesregierung
was wir heute beschließen ist die
corona-schutzmaßnahmen
Ausnahmeverordnung und die
einreiseverordnung und das ist dann auch
ein wichtiger Bestandteil wir müssen
damit rechnen dass in Zukunft ein großer
Teil der Bevölkerung sich mit der
omegonvariante infizieren wird wir sehen
in einigen Regionen Englands
eine
infektionsprävalenz eine sozusagen
infektions Verbreitung zu einem
gegebenen Zeitpunkt von zehn Prozent das
haben wir in der gesamten Pandemie noch
nie irgendwo gesehen das sind höhere
Prävalenzen als wir sie sehen in
ärmerländern wo keinerlei Impfung
vorliegt wenn in England aber die
Situation die ist das von den Geimpften
85 Prozent geboostet sind das ist die
Situation wenn die Zahl derer die älter
ist und die nicht geimpft sind sehr
gering ist und ich habe da trotzdem
Prävalenzen von zum Teil zehn Prozent
dann sehen wir wie ansteckend diese
Variante ist das haben wir noch nie in
dieser Situation beobachtet daher müssen
wir uns vorbereiten wir gehen wir denn
dann mit der quarantäne-regelung und wir
haben versucht die Quarantäne Dauer so
stark zu verkürzen wie dies medizinisch
möglich ist aber nicht noch mehr
verkürzen so dass wir nicht ins Risiko
gehen also wir wollen dass die
Quarantäne so kurz ist wie sie sein kann
insbesondere für diejenigen die in den
medizinischen Bereichen arbeiten
Krankenhaus Altenpflege
behindertenversorgung dass man dort nach
sieben Tagen nach einer pcr-testung
wieder in den Beruf zurückkehren kann
aber wir haben es nicht noch stärker
verkürzen können hätten wir es auf fünf
Tage verkürzt wäre beim Abschlusstest
zumindest bei denjenigen die einen
antigen-test nehmen ungefähr ein Viertel
falsch negativ gewesen das heißt die
Menschen wären noch ansteckend gewesen
wir hätten sie aber negativ getestet und
weil wir das nicht tragen wollten sind
wir bei sieben Tagen geblieben diese
Debatte haben wir ja geführt konstruktiv
geführt und so sind wir zu einem
gemeinsamen Ergebnis gekommen an
Ergebnis für welches ich mich hier noch
mal bedanken möchte und das Ergebnis ist
ja sehr komplex wir verweisen in den
beiden Verordnungen auf Regeln die also
durch das Robert-Koch-Institut und das
paul Ehrlich Institut erläutert werden
und präzisiert werden weil das ist kein
verordnungsgegenstand da muss auf
medizinische Inhalte verwiesen werden
trotzdem sage ich ihnen zu erstens ist
es alles und das ist ja auch von ihren
Häusern geprüft worden genauso umgesetzt
worden wie wir es besprochen hatten
zweitens Veränderungen finden nur statt
ohne politischen Einfluss
ausschließlich auf silikonlage neuer
wissenschaftlicher Erkenntnisse also
ohne eine Beeinflussung durch den
Minister zum Beispiel und zum dritten
wir informieren sie so dass sie nicht
regelmäßig sich diese Sage ihre
verweisen anschauen müssen und prüfen
hat sich da etwas verändert sondern
selbstverständlich also bekommen sie
dann von uns entsprechende Nachricht und
wenn von ihnen Einwände vorgetragen
werden dann werden die natürlich
berücksichtigt aber diese Lösung die wir
jetzt gefunden haben ist aus meiner
Sicht eine gute Lösung weil sie ist
flexibel wir können schnell reagieren
wir können immer den neuesten
wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisstand
abbilden wir haben aber gleichzeitig
auch eine rechtlich sichere Grundlage
und daher glaube ich ist das eine Lösung
mit der wir arbeiten können wir werden
aus meiner Sicht
mittelfristig diese Pandemie nur
bekämpfen können erfolgreich bekämpfen
können wenn wir über das was wir jetzt
hier machen hinausgehen was wir machen
muss ja auch strategisch irgendwie
beschrieben werden ich will zwar wie
folgt beschreiben was wir derzeit machen
ist omecon baut wenn man nicht viel
Macht automatisch eine Wand auf die
sogenannte ormicon-wand man läuft dann
in diese Wand hinein dann steigen die
Fallzahlen sehr Stahl an und wenn dann
sehr viele infiziert sind fällt die Wand
wieder ab das ist die typische omicon
Wand und was wir unternehmen ist im
Prinzip wir versuchen aus dieser Wand
einen Hügel zu machen mit geringeren
infektions- und Sterbezahlen oder wenn
uns das nicht gelingt das ist nicht
ausgemacht dass es uns gelingt an Hügel
zu machen eine Wand die nicht so hoch
ist weil damit verhindern wir
Todesfälle damit verhindern wir schwere
Erkrankungen damit verhindern wir long
kovid-fälle aber wir müssen
realistischerweise einräumen wir einen
Hügel haben wir sind nicht auf dem
Höhepunkt der Fallzahlen angekommen das
muss eingeräumt werden wir werden
möglicherweise auch in einer Wand hinein
geraten aber wenn wir in einer Wand
hineingeraten dann ist das eine Wand die
nicht so hoch ist wie die Wand die wir
sonst erfahren hätten wir wollen das was
uns in der Vergangenheit gelungen ist
dass wir eine Sterblichkeit haben die
geringer ist als sie gewesen wäre ohne
unsere Maßnahmen das wollen wir
wiederholen daher haben wir auch viele
kontaktbegrenzungen weiter in am Platz
ich höre oft wann macht er endlich
kontaktbegrenzungen die kontakttzahl die
in Deutschland derzeit gemessen wird
ausgemessen wird ist nur halb so hoch
wie vor dem Beginn der Pandemie das
heißt wir haben zahlreiche
kontaktbegrenzungen haben wir weiter am
Platz wir fahren an für sich eine
relativ vorsichtige Strategie die ich
auch für richtig halte sie wird uns aber
langfristig aus der Pandemie nicht
befallen
wir müssen im Herbst mit neuen Varianten
rechnen
es ist so dass also von den
Wissenschaftlern die hier tief
eingearbeitet sind und ich bin mit
vielen in Kontakten nicht nur hier in
Deutschland
gibt es ganz wenige ich will nicht sagen
niemanden aber ganz wenige die sagen
omekon ist die letzte große Variante das
sagt vielleicht einer von 100 aber es
werden nicht viel mehr sein 99 andere
sagen es geht weiter und wenn es
weitergeht dann müssen auch wir
weitermachen wir können nicht aufhören
wir können nicht sagen mit
Omegon hören wir jetzt auf
Omegon wird die Pandemie auch deshalb
nicht beenden wenn es jetzt tatsächlich
so wäre was wir verhindern werden aber
wenn es tatsächlich so wäre die
ungeimpften würden sich alle mit omekon
anstecken das ist ja auch ein Gedanke
der manchmal vorgetragen wird das wird
die Pandemie nicht beenden auch nicht
für die ungeimpften weil die Infektion
mit Omegon vor weiteren Varianten nicht
viel Schutz selbst vor der Delta
Variante habe ich nur einen Schutz wenn
ich frisch gerade an omikon infiziert
war von etwa 50 Prozent schauen wir ein
paar Monate nach vorne planen da
vielleicht 24 Prozent übrig dann habe
ich eine 80 prozentige wurnerabilität
gegen neue Varianten und diese werden im
Herbst natürlich kommen wir werden auch
im Sommer saisonal eine gute Zeit
erleben aber dann kommt der Herbst und
die gute Zeit ist vorbei und was ich
falsch finde wenn wir dann die
Gelegenheit verpasst hätten die
impfboote zu erreichen die notwendige
ist um neue Varianten tatsächlich
so zu beherrschen dass wir sagen können
wir brauchen wesentliche Einschränkungen
nicht mehr weil jeder ist so
grundimmunisiert dass er nicht schwer
erkranken wird oder sterben muss in der
Kombination wir hätten eine
Grundimmunisierung auch der älteren
vulnerablen geschafft und wir haben dann
Medikamente wie paxlovit oder andere
oder manipuliere zur Hand dann wären wir
ja durch werden dann die
Grundimmunisierung und die
unvermeidbaren Fälle können wir
medikamentös in den Griff bekommen wir
hätten es ja geschafft das wäre ja der
Punkt das schaffen wir aus meiner Sicht
nur wenn wir eine allgemeine Impfpflicht
einführen ich persönlich glaube nicht
dass wir die also Impfquote erreichen um
diesen Weg erfolgreich gehen zu können
gemeinsam gehen zu können ohne
allgemeine Impfpflicht ja dass wir
ausgeschlossen ich bin jemand der den
ungeimpften keine Vorwürfe macht ich
lade die ungeimpften auch die
ungeimpften die uns jetzt zuhören ein
sich noch impfen zu lassen zumindest die
erste Impfung sich schützt schon vor
schwere Krankheit
ich bin auch der Meinung dass ungeimpfte
genauso behandelt werden sollten wie
geimpfte auch das ist
ein Gebot unseres Humanismus ich
behandle es acht zum Beispiel Menschen
mit der
gleichen Hingabe wie andere wenn es sich
um Menschen handelt die an Tal ihr
Schicksal selbst verursacht haben
übergewichtige Raucher beispielsweise
Menschen die krebserkrankt sind weil sie
über 30 Jahre geraucht haben für mich
sind das Arzt alle gleich ich schaue
nicht nach ich schaue einfach nach vorne
schauen nicht nach hinten wie ist das
gekommen sind alle gleich und so blicke
ich auch auf ungeimpfte ich habe daher
keine Risse und dements gegen umgeimpft
überhaupt nicht
aber trotzdem können wir auch etwas von
den ungeimpften verlangen wir alle
erbringen so viele Opfer für so lange
die kontaktbeschränkungen die
Gastronomie die Geschäfte die 50 Prozent
Einschränkungen die ich eben beschrieben
haben die Mittel die wir einsetzen die
vielen Milliarden die wir einsetzen um
diese Maßnahmen zu begreifen ich bin
wahrscheinlich im Moment der teuerste
Minister der Bundesregierung es vergeht
nicht eine Woche wo ich Milliarden
Beträge
veranlassen muss weil es einfach gar
nicht anders geht wir alle bringen Opfer
die größten Opfer bringen unsere Kinder
meine eigene Tochter die die Kinder
bringen jetzt Opfer für so lange ich bin
da der Meinung dass sie das von den
ungeimpften verlangen können dass sie
eine fast
nebenwirkungsfreie Impfung die
wissenschaftlich nicht strittig steht
dass sie diese Impfung auch akzeptieren
das sehe ich also
nicht einfach altmodisch als Mensch da
sehe ich mich auch in der Tradition der
Aufklärung da sehe ich mich ehrlich
gesagt also ich will das nicht überhören
aber auch also in der Pflicht Tradition
von Kant da werden wir alles so denken
würden also ich will jetzt in Kategorien
Imperativ nicht vortragen damit habe ich
gestern schon den Bundestag erschrocken
aber wenn ich also wenn ich das also
wenn ich das also wenn jetzt alles so
denken würde wenn wir jetzt alle sagen
würden ja ich bin gesund ich brauche die
Impfung nicht oder also ich
ernähre mich gesund ich will das nicht
oder ich glaube an also
andere medizinische Grundrichtungen so
wenn wir alle werden wir alle für uns in
Anspruch nehmen dass wir es nicht nötig
haben oder besser wissen oder also nicht
mitmachen wollen oder dann andere
Staatsverständnis haben und so dann
würden wir im Chaos enden im chaosenden
von daher bin ich für die allgemeine
Impfpflicht ich hoffe dass wir dieses
Thema
so schnell jetzt anschieben können ich
plädiere auch an alle bitte machen Sie
es nicht zur Parteipolitik bitte machen
Sie es nicht zur Parteipolitik wir
dürfen uns in dieser wichtigen Frage
nicht auseinander dividieren lassen wir
dürfen uns nicht streiten ich verstehe
dass es auch unter uns solche gibt die
sagen das muss so schnell wie möglich
gehen das hätte ich näher schneller
gehen müssen und so weiter und so fort
aber bitte keine Parteipolitik wir
versuchen es wirklich hinzubekommen der
Bundestag arbeitet an Vorschlägen ich
bin mit Gruppen des Bundestags im
Kontakt und weiß das gearbeitet wird ich
kann mich da als
Bundesgesundheitsminister nicht also als
aktiver Spieler einbringen weil das in
gruppenanträge wo wichtige ethische
Fragen berührt werden aber wir können
das gemeinsam hinbekommen ich glaube
eine Mehrheit der Bevölkerung wird
diesen Weg mit uns gehen und lassen mich
noch einen Punkt sagen es soll niemand
dazu gezwungen werden einen bestimmten
Impfstoff zu nehmen wir haben ja Gott
sei Dank das Luxusproblem in Deutschland
ich habe allein seit Amtsantritt
55 Millionen Dosen boosterimpfung
gekauft
und
noch einmal 80 Millionen Dosen Impfstoff
der genutzt werden könnte für eine
Impfpflicht wir hatten Impfstoff dass
jeder dreimal geimpft werden könnte ich
habe veranlasst dass die Impfzentren bis
zum Jahresende offen bleiben dass wir
nicht also die Situation kommen ihr
macht eine Impfpflicht ihr habt nicht
ebenfalls sie hat nicht die Impfzentren
ihr habt keinen Impfstoff und so weiter
das ist alles vorbereitet wir gehen hier
in die Vorlage mit sehr hohen Kosten
obwohl die endlich noch gar nicht da ist
weil wir bereit sein wollen wenn es
tatsächlich so weit kommt daher ist es
vorbereitet und ich habe auch also
novawachs Impfstoff besorgt an Tod
Impfstoff da werden wir am 21.2
dass die Datum konnte ich mir gut merken
dass mein Geburtstag werden wir 1,75
Millionen Dosen als erste Lieferung vom
Hersteller bekommen so dass wir auch den
Tod Impfstoff anbieten können somit wir
tun wirklich alles was wir können wir
beraten das vor ich habe hier meine
persönliche Position zum Thema
vorgetragen ich glaube das ist eine
Position die von vielen Wissenschaftlern
geteilt wird und was bedeutsam ist die
wurde ja auch von allen
ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz getan sie
wird von Bundeskanzler Scholz geteilt
von mir geteilt wirklich glaube ich wir
stehen da alle zusammen somit können wir
es beenden wir sollten es beenden und
ich weiß wenn wir es beenden dann werden
wir es beenden mit der Hilfe dieses
Gremiums ich darf Ihnen ganz herzlich
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit danken
lieber Herr Professor Dr Lauterbach
haben sie herzlichen Dank für das
emotional klar beschriebene Ziel das uns
alle umtreibt und in diesem Sinne wollen
wir gerne unsere Ärmel hochkrempeln und
unseres dazutun vielen Dank gibt es
weitere Wortmeldungen das kann ich nicht
erkennen
Ausschussberatungen haben nicht
stattgefunden wir sind übereingekommen
bereits heute in der Sache zu
entscheiden wer stimmt der Verordnung zu
damit stelle ich fest dass es einstimmig
von Bundesrat bestätigt und damit zu
angenommen worden ich darf Ihnen ganz
herzlich danken es ist damit so
Beschlusslage für unsere weitere Arbeit
Herr Bundesgesundheitsminister hatte
angekündigt dass wir Erläuterungen dazu
bekommen darauf hatte auch Volker
Bouffier im Vorgespräch schon
hingewiesen dass wir das Miteinander gut
synchronisieren müssen damit da keine
Lücken in den Argumentationen und auch
in den rechtlichen Verordnungen
entstehen auch dafür schon mein
herzlichen Dank wir haben die
Tagesordnung für heute
gemeinsam bewältigt die nächste Sitzung
des Bundesrates beruflich für Freitag
den 11 Februar ein um 9 Uhr halten sie
weiterhin Abstand bleiben sie fröhlich
und lassen Sie uns gemeinsam die
nächsten Etappen angehen ich darf Ihnen
herzlich danken alles Gute wünschen die
Sitzung ist geschlossen
[Musik]